amo a mi esposa pero soy gay debería
confesárselo Ahora sí o no
reunimos a un grupo de desconocidos para
ayudar a una persona a tomar una
decisión difícil mi esposa es la persona
más importante de mi vida y nunca
querría hacer nada que le hiciera daño
pero también soy gay no estoy seguro de
cómo enfocarlo o incluso de cómo
decírselo después de escuchar los
consejos del grupo Qué lección hará la
persona esto es El dilema El dilema
parte 1 preguntas y respuestas En qué
parte de la relación te diste cuenta de
que eras gay
lo sabía antes de casarme
como la conociste
crecimos juntos en la misma comunidad
empezamos como amigos luego como mejores
amigos y a partir de ahí nos juntamos tu
pareja te apoya en todo lo que haces
en nuestros puntos de vista sobre la
religión Sí en cuanto al apoyo a la
comunidad lgbt no entonces la religión
es la piedra angular de su relación
ambos crecimos en la misma comunidad
religiosa con los mismos valores y las
mismas pautas sociales Así que sí
crees que tu esposa sabe que eres gay no
no lo sabe cuál fue la razón principal
por la que decidiste el sí tengo algunos
familiares en la comunidad
lgbt-cumas sé que todas sus experiencias
al salir del clóset han sido positivas
al menos a largo plazo Pensé en que
viniera aquí queriendo compartir su
verdad y hablarnos de ello sabía que ya
era hora que estaba empezando a
erosionar y que debía confesarlo qué te
motivó a casarte con una mujer sabiendo
que eras gay pensé que sí me casaba
cambiaría y que podría volverme
heterosexual
Cuáles son tus intenciones en la vida y
cómo quieres que se sienta vivir
quiero ser sincero pero tampoco quiero
herir a la gente que me rodea soy una
persona muy honesta no miento Así que el
hecho de que esté viviendo básicamente
una mentira ahora mismo me produce mucha
ansiedad y depresión pero sé que si
salgo del clóset así de pronto la
devastaría El caso es que soy bisexual y
nunca hubiera dicho nada si acababa
encontrando el amor en un hombre y no
funcionaba o si me enamoraba de una
mujer y no quería esconderme más ser tu
auténtico yo es mi lema entonces hay
alguna consecuencia esperada que se
extienda Más allá de la relación de ti y
tu esposa está en juego algo más que la
relación de ustedes dos
mi trabajo está vinculado a la iglesia
Así que podría perder mi trabajo tal vez
perdería a mi familia mis amigos mi
esposa lo perdería todo básicamente no
tendría nada ni apoyo somos los únicos
que sabemos sobre esto
nunca le he dicho a nadie
basándonos en esta información pueden
cambiarse al otro lado si quieren
no lo sé
[Risas]
estaba explicando lo que está en juego
si confiesa Ahora cuanto más pensaba en
eso más me decía va a perder
literalmente todo por esto siento que
necesita algún tipo de plan de
movimiento en primer lugar la razón por
la que dije que no es que soy bisexual
igual que tú me tomó tiempo asimilarlo
es algo que miro más como estás a salvo
Si te vas podrías perder muchas cosas
que has construido sobre esa base has
pensado en acudir a terapia o algún tipo
de asesoramiento para que te ayude con
este proceso
en la comunidad en la que vivo Es un
poco difícil hallar asesoramiento vive
en una zona rural por lo que la mayoría
de los consejeros se basan en lo que
demanda la iglesia
puedes hablarme un poco más de su
relación con Dios y si han habido
momentos en los que
has experimentado personalmente cómo te
guía sí diría que la fe ha sido un
factor decisivo en todas las cosas que
hago en mi vida y que no sigo a Dios
ciegamente ya lo he sentido actuar en mi
vida así que para mí es una relación
real que tengo y es la relación más
importante que tengo Dios está por
encima de todo lo demás
La fe es un factor enorme para mi verdad
para mí eso es lo que más resuena quería
ser la representación de Oye si vas con
fe aún podría funcionar
si muestras quién eres realmente a
alguien a cualquiera te va a mostrar A
quiénes son el 100% de las veces y si te
rodeas de gente que no apoya a la
persona que eres no es una situación
saludable creo que debería confesarlo al
100% Hoy soy bisexual me costó
asimilarlo uno de mis no tiene nombres
un familiar le dijo a mis padres me dio
mucha ansiedad era como me van a echar
están molestos conmigo no entiendo fue
muy parecido a bien como quieras sé que
al principio todo el mundo te dice Hazlo
hazlo es genial Te sentirás mejor pero
para mí salir del clóset fue lo peor
porque viví mi verdad pero no me
hicieron sentir como yo quería creo que
todo el mundo debe vivir su no eres
emocionalmente responsable de nadie no
le debes a nadie tu vida sé tú y ellos
descubrirán como ser ellos creo que es
diferente dices que no eres responsable
de los sentimientos de los demás Pero lo
eres sé que la culpa que sentiría como
esposo de estar ocultando algo mi esposa
sería horrible Sí porque tampoco
olvidemos que están casados tienen votos
y parte de esos votos es decir la verdad
saben a qué me refiero porque le estás
quitando a la otra persona la
posibilidad de vivir en la realidad y
eso está mal quiero señalar que no estoy
diciendo necesariamente que debe esperar
años para decirlo solo digo que no No
para nada solo un par de meses Yo diría
que fueras a terapia que te aconsejen
que descubras quién eres incluso fuera
de la iglesia y sin tu esposa y todas
esas cosas una vez que descubras todo
eso puedes empezar a pasar por ese
proceso pero creo que el enfoque Debería
ser más el hecho de encontrarse a sí
mismo toda esa planificación
y esas cosas son preguntas difíciles
pero no tienen que ser respondidas ahora
mismo porque todo es paso a paso
salir del clóset no es arrancar una
bandita desemboca en mucha ansiedad
viene con tantas
recaídas dependiendo de quién seas De
dónde se alinea tu comunidad entiendes y
no debería arrancarse sin más porque
incluso arrancar las banditas duele No
no es un proceso fácil solo porque sea
rápido y la gente tiene que entenderlo
hubo algo en el debate que te llamara la
atención de alguna manera
creo que cuando mencionaron que al salir
del clóset en este momento las personas
mostrarán su verdadera cara eso resonó
en mí porque es cierto la otra cuestión
que se planteó fue el punto de
asesoramiento y el tipo de preparación
siento que podría ser beneficioso
creo que se ha discutido demasiado sobre
cuál es el paso 10 cuál es el paso siete
qué hacemos dentro de estas etapas creo
que eso es lo que conseguirá lo que
necesita de nosotros es Al fin y al cabo
la gente va a hacer lo que es y no se
puede predecir como va a reaccionar
además he conocido gente que ha estado
en peligro por haber salido del clóset
nuestra mayor preocupación es su
seguridad encontrar una comunidad
una cosa de la que hablamos fue que no
necesitas un plan porque tu dilema no es
confesarlo al mundo en este momento sino
solo a tu esposa como tu pareja y como
un hombre casado de fe
dijiste que ella creció en la iglesia
contigo crecieron en la iglesia y si tu
esposa posee esos frutos del espíritu
que son la paciencia y la bondad creo
que esos atributos como has dicho están
en ella y por eso ella sería cariñosa
amable y paciente contigo una de las
cosas que quiero animarte ya que has
estado en una posición vulnerable en la
que has tenido que poner toda tu
confianza en Dios y él te ha ayudado es
que estés bien con dar solo el primer
paso hacia adelante y todo lo demás lo
puedas averiguar en el camino bueno en
primer lugar quiero dejar Claro que sí
deberías confesarlo pero sin duda es
mejor esperar y dar un poco más de
tiempo ya que nos preocupa tu seguridad
en primer lugar la otra cosa también es
que necesitas recursos tiempo para
conseguirlos como dije estos procesos de
divorcio y todo lo demás no tardan una
semana y luego se trata de tu comunidad
personalmente en mi familia son súper
religiosos Así que comprendo
perfectamente que inviertas tanto tiempo
en tu comunidad y la sensación de
pérdida que conlleva pero tienes que
entender que estarás bien tu relación
con Dios estará bien pero esta es una
decisión muy dura que es más que eso
Jacob cómo te sientes en este momento
siento que tengo muchas
palabras útiles que me han ayudado a
armar una idea de lo que quiero hacer en
adelante pudiste tomar una decisión
Sí eso creo
[Música]
al llegar a casa le dije a mi esposa que
quería hacer terapia y nos reunimos con
una consejera maravillosa que nos ha
dado muchas herramientas para trabajar
Nos reunimos uno a uno así que tengo la
oportunidad de ser muy abierto con ella
sobre cómo me siento creo que en los
próximos meses
estaré listo para salir del clóset
prepararme y preparar a mi esposa para
esa noticia
[Música]
siento que me quité un poco el peso de
encima todavía tengo que recorrer mucho
y va a ser Duro De cualquier manera pero
siento un poco de cierre en el sentido
de que sé lo que quiero hacer ahora es
una decisión que debe tomarse con
fidelidad a través de Dios creo que
también es una decisión que se toma con
la ayuda de un consejero es justo para
mi esposa que cuando salga del clóset lo
haga de una manera que no solo sea
segura para mí sino también para ella y
que me asegure de tener los recursos que
necesito En caso de que algo salga mal
Gracias estamos orgullosos
de las personas con las que me he
sincerado sobre esto así que esto fue sé
que si te topas con ese muro de no
siento que alguien me va a apoyar nadie
me cubre la espalda sabes que te
cubrimos la espalda en espíritu Desde la
distancia Tienes gente que cree en ti y
que te va a apoyar qué quiere que seas
feliz y te lo mereces sí